we are twins baby yes we are the young
in the game right we both are wearing
custom mark zunino both wearing 14 karat
from our friend Helen we are in we are
in sync in martini no does he not make
most beautiful mark we love you thank
you beyond yes okay so as the president
like you are like the lady here you can
walk through the C's Park all right it's
a big night and heaven because it's the
25th anniversary it's a lot to take it
is I think so exciting 25 years and you
know we have some of the original
there's time winners here tonight this
to me is I've been like facetiming this
and putting it out I'm excited it's
gonna be a great great night
I mean having Tom Hanks and Jodie Foster
both of them here who won the first
actor Awards crazy really crazy and they
are such incredible inspiration so
tonight's gonna be a fabulous night
really great everybody you know we love
award season and all of them are so
great but all of the actors I talked to
say this one's a little bit more special
for them because it's their peers saying
job well done you know what there's
nothing I don't think any higher calling
than to have peer to peer recognition
right we love the idea that the audience
loves us but when you're working with
other actors were broadcast anybody's
doing the work and you love their work
and they recognize you that as the
highest compliment so this is important
okay so from what I hear there was a
group of you 9:02 one hour's meeting
about a reboot what can you tell me I
can tell you that's true can tell you
that's true please tell me this is gonna
have I'm gonna tell you I I can't say
any more than you know what if you loved
us then
now you love us now you make my heart
flutter you're making me do palpitations
because listen really you were like the
voice of my generation I remember it was
when Fox first started put it into
networking right I was a freshman in
college when you guys went to college we
used to gather around the television and
watch every night and we're so excited
every week for the show we need this
back well you know what I can't even
tell you how exciting is to be with my
cast mates I love them so much and for
us to have all these years we had our
children now we've been doing our lives
and we're coming together I don't know
what it will look like right now you'll
have to see but when I hit everybody
[Music]